have you ever run into any like
celebrity crushes any of your yes yes I
wrote about one in my book so I had a
crush on Michael Fassbender yeah you had
one so it's over I it's kind of over in
that he's married and it's relevant time
but what I met him it was I was I was
newly familiar with him but I didn't
realize it was him when I met him
because he was sitting I was behind and
so he was talking to me this way so I
didn't really get a full look at his
face and had this whole conversation he
was super super charming and then when I
left I was walking out and I said you
know Michael and my friend who was with
me I was like you know like black girls
a big Donham until it was already too
late and then I was mad because on on
parks of Rack my character names her car
after Michael that's better because it's
a Mercedes she names it Michael
Fassbender because it's German and it's
sexy later Jamie sexy and I just played
myself and then like a year later I saw
him at the Golden Globe so worried about
it's not good all those so we're at the
gun clubs and my publicist changed he
was like two people down for me on the
carpet and I literally was like what's
wrong with you I was like and she's like
my man introduced you I was like I will
kill you where you stand
I get so embarrassed yeah unless I
embarrass myself right yeah then it's
the globe's so it's a lot of cocktails
yeah not for me I got terrified I was
like I'm not drinking I already make a
fool of myself sober yeah they had
already taken they'd already taken all
the food off the table so it was just
liquor they want me to get drunk yeah
champagne all night and there was a
point where he walked up and we were
sitting not far from the bathroom so
everybody who had to go the bathroom had
to pass our table and there was I don't
really remember this I found this out
after
because I had a lot of traits but my EP
had said to us yeah you don't remember
Michael faster I was like no he's like
he walked up to the table he smiled at
you instead of responded you just leave
back it said you know like black girls
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you missed our you paid yourself twice
you just really did not want him and
inside your body I think well congratu
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I like that there is or head below that
is not what I meant I mean like deep
inside some of your subconscious
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going